basically my mom gets like real kicks
off the Jets and stairs and she's like
some watch you're not transport movie
like hi my name is John Newman and this
is bucking timeline for light Bible
that's right one party who did I
describe as violent I didn't see I
remember the picture but I also remember
I got married dogs and and I also
remember many arguments and don't want
anymore
ellie goulding yeah we got inside I love
that crowd too so much well see this is
me tweeting is awful what did this fun
say it was really good
a little bit bother me in turn is that
close Oh free Wi-Fi I love you mom free
Wi-Fi that is so amazing she definitely
held that for everybody is lucky who did
I describe as brother from another
mother the little teddy bear guy sure
blindspot replied to me life girls who
made me excited fire fine to me I
remember Tyson Fury is that right I have
pizza Tyson Fury did Walter I know you
followed me
maybe what they prefer beats a heart i
superior probably pizza it's more
reliable source of friendship
Jermaine I can't take my wife to Tyson
Fury dolls for dinner come on an
impressive but can I take it to Peter
[Laughter]
yes yes yes this guy makes me smile
every single day with his vibe this foot
is incredible it was the other night of
the Brits after-party yeah I look like
some weird form of bird and my missus is
like I can always tell when you're
absolutely smashed because it's like
you're touching cloth and you like
southerly whole Josh together is Brad
from Vance on Lewis Capaldi irritable in
that picture he looks a bit like a thumb
with a mop on it who was this lovely man
who sent a message to my mum it's Jason
Statham hello Jackie I hope you have a
lovely Christmas I said you look so low
basically my mum gets like real kicks
off the chairs and stairs and she's like
some watch you not transport movie like
I text Rosie and said Jim Jason cats mmm
a video and he sent it and then a person
and said thank you very much and then he
rolled back after huh
well I don't know whether I was meant to
post it that's the thing I was like I'm
gonna stick to my guns like Jason
Statham talking to my mum I'm sticking
there that's the right thing to do what
is one was like tweet of all time
with your funds like we need missus
recently it's a bit like example example
what is new to know and then you know I
did alright and then he puts out a video
of his mrs. Johnson in the NICUs Realty
sure millions of people start hearing it
and he was like what's going on here
you know I've been working harder means
to government interactions and insights
and all this stuff soon as a post
picture of me and my missus on my
wedding [ __ ] 4009 is that in it yeah
the day I got married to the greatest
woman in the world she is a vibe massive
vibe that's it
my name is John Heyman and this was back
in timeline I know my social media
[Laughter]
[Music]